and but I had a day one ambition today  after talking with him he he always says  this thing he always says the only time  a company dies is when the founder quits  and for a while I was like all right  fun cliche sounds good but now that I'm  into this ways it's so true right like  the only time a company fails is when  the founder says I am no longer gonna  push the ball up the hill anymore right  maybe it's because you got another job  offer there's an opportunity cost maybe  it's because you ran out of money maybe  it's because you had a kid life happened  right like but a lot of founders just  push through these milestones like month  after quarter after year right and the  ones that just don't give up I've seen  founders burn it down to zero from 400  employees and then rebuild and build  multi-million hundred million dollar  companies again right and so you just